well honored is
an understatement to be here with both
of you thank you so for spending so much
of your time
you didn't get to any twitter questions
no well
a question i had mick if you all have
two more minutes if this can even be
answered in two minutes is that there's
this phrase the vastness of space or the
vastness of the universe so given that
and our supposed
insignificance in it and uh scientists
always like to point that out
masochistically though i think that's
sadistic and not masochistic
so seeing how unbelievably finite we are
is it so improbable that we're being
examined or kept as livestock by
creatures beyond our comprehension given
that we do that for virtually every
other species so if one wants to say
well where's the evidence well virtually
all the evidence that we have is one
more intelligent species looking at
another lower intelligence species
which can't even cognitively grasp that
there's someone higher than them
i think it's it's kind of an
unanswerable question because we don't
really have enough uh data about the
universe to to answer like to figure out
like how common life is
in the universe and what it would have
done how it would have spread through
the universe and
i really just for me it boils down to
sure it's possible
yeah i'm a science fiction fan and i
read all kinds of hypotheses about
you know kind of
gardens uh like the earth being a
cultured thing like and the aliens are
watching us and just waiting for us to
discover a certain bit of physics that
uh it becomes dangerous and then they'll
step in and sure yeah it's it sounds
plausible
but
is there any evidence that it's
happening
and there it really isn't so it's
something that i think you would keep on
the table in the same way that you would
keep the simulation hypothesis
on the table
but it's not something that really
has an effect
in what we do from day to day
you know i don't go around like changing
what i do based on the simulation
hypothesis or the possibility that we're
being kept in a garden by aliens
but it's something that i wouldn't
eliminate as a possibility
okay eric eric do you have any quick
comments on that
um
you know i
i i guess that we don't have any really
good way of
coming up with the bayesian prior
um
the vastness of space
indicates to me that it's very unlikely
that we're the only sentient life in it
the
difficulty of crossing the vastness of
space
according to einsteinian restrictions
gives me
some sense that even if life is abundant
it may be forever trapped locally where
it is if it's based on waves
reverberating in this space uh
without too much alteration in our
fundamental ideas so there are
countervailing forces pointing in very
opposite directions to me as to why we
are functionally
quite likely to be alone
and why we are very unlikely
statistically to be
alone even if we are functionally
isolated
with all that said
um
[Music]
i i'm motivated and i believe that we
should always try to understand our own
motivated reasoning and my worst piece
of motivated reasoning is
if nobody is able to visit us
it probably means that we're doomed
and
if we have a hope of not being doomed
it's almost certainly because we were
able to survive the period where we had
god-like powers but only one shared
atmosphere
because any idiot with the god-like
powers can sort of end the experiment at
will
and as a result
if there aren't aliens here
i would think that we are far more
likely to die soon
on moss
because there really isn't a lot of hope
for leaving
so the desire for aliens
and again i don't really love the idea
of being anybody's pet in a zoo or a rat
in a maze
so it's not like i'm sitting there
hoping
that the aliens are there and they're
benevolent um
but if nobody is able to visit us i
think the odds that we are going to be
able to leave and survive
dwindle to
close to zero
and so i'm very hopeful
that the universe is not only
um
inundated with life from various places
but that much of that life figures out
that the theories beyond those we know
contain hope and options
even if they risk limitless power
we already have the power to destroy
ourselves so physics led us into the
valley of death
what we have to ask is
if you push farther into the valley of
death with physics is there a way out
okay
thank you all
i'm gonna go talk to my wife all right
thank you guys if you're ever in in
southern california let me buy you a
beer
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n
that is kurt jymungal it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you